m
[Musique]
128 ans après sa création à new york la
symphonie du nouveau monde résonnera
dans la grande salle de l'équinoxe
dimanche 17 octobre tout un symbole pour
châteauroux marqué par l'influencé
américaine au coeur de son centre-ville
l'équinox ravive les relations
transatlantiques en invitant cinq
artistes américains pour cette saison
dédiée au nouveau monde au sens large
paroles d'artistes en exil
[Musique]
danse et musique électronique
les nouveaux mondes sont multiples les
nouveaux mondes c'est aussi les nouveaux
territoires culturels à découvrir c'est
à dire ces moments où on s'échappe où on
s'échappe des disciplines où on
s'échappe aussi de ce que l'on connaît
pour aller vers plus tôt à territoire à
découvrir un peu comme christophe colomb
allez un peu à l'aventuré rencontrant
des gens qu'il n'avait jamais vue
auparavant c'est un peu ça qu'on veut
provoquer ce goût de la rencontre des
rencontres entre spectacles vivants et
cinéma c'est ce que prévoit d'organiser
l'équinoxe en décembre prochain denis
podalydès jouera sur les planches de la
grande salle le public pour ensuite
échanger avec lui au cinéma l'apollo
j'ignore si l'extérieur est devant moi
ou au dessus de moi et si même il ya
encore un extérieur
rencontré denis podalydès qui nous parle
dans un moment extrêmement privilégiés
on est avec lui en chair et en os et qui
nous adressent une comme ça une parole
je pense que c'est des moments marquants
qu'on a très envie de partager et de
transmettre tous les mois le public de
la polo aura l'occasion de découvrir les
nouvelles sorties cinématographiques des
films jeune public mais également des
classiques